foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday February 6th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
as artificial intelligence Technologies
become a bigger part of our everyday
lives a lot of people are asking how
much can we trust it
that question is one that wsj reporter
Eric neeler and researcher and inventor
ramachalapa try to answer in their book
titled appropriately enough can we trust
AI in a recent live q a Eric and Rama
looked at one particular area where
trust in AI plays a big role
Healthcare
they spoke with wsj live journalism news
editor Sarah Castellanos about it here
are highlights from their conversation
so welcome to both of you it's so great
to have you here so AI is being
experimented with across so many sectors
to you know varying degrees of success
you guys mentioned a number of examples
in your book what are some of the most
Cutting Edge uses of AI and Healthcare
specifically today Eric do you want to
start
sure
um
AI really feeds on large amounts of data
and
um Healthcare and Medicine generate a
lot of data uh in the sense of screens
of the body tumor biopsies
photographs of skin lesions these sorts
of things data from patient records in
the hospital vital signs a real endless
list of information that is collected
about a patient's health
so people who are able to combine Ai and
and Medicine are right on this Cutting
Edge of being able to take a computer
algorithm with a large amount of data to
look for patterns that otherwise just
would be impossible or just take too
long to figure out so that's what we're
looking at right now and it really cuts
across a lot of fields in medicine
so tell us a little bit about the sort
of the AI and
um covid example here I mean Eric it
seems like it was used but potentially
AI was used but potentially not to Great
Lengths or to great effect right right
and so what was happening is at the time
um uh doctors and computer scientists
and data Engineers were working together
is there a way to predict
hospitalization for covid when a patient
comes in if they show these sorts of
Vital Signs these sorts of symptoms
can we say that this person
um you know either has kobit how they're
gonna um how long it's gonna take for
them to recover what kind of
hospitalization rates should we prepare
for a big surge of patients you know uh
if we're seeing these sorts of things in
our in the population and so there was a
lot of attempts to to do this and
um some of the later review studies that
six months or a year later look back on
that initial 2020 surge
um found out that
um
it it really didn't do so well there was
um there was a problem with
um people coming in with what's called
comorbidities or different different
sort of
um
symptoms and health effects may maybe
that it led to to a covet infection that
kind of threw things off there were also
different hospitals having different
sorts of patient populations
um you know large Urban medical centers
rural clinics uh Suburban dock in the
Box you know all these different places
were getting uh coveted patients and so
trying to pull all this data together
and to have a big enough data set to
train the algorithm it was really
difficult and it was a very fast-moving
epidemic as well a fast-moving virus and
evolving virus so I think folks have
learned a lot from that
um and I think we'll see what happens
you know in the future and how they're
able to take these algorithms and maybe
do a planning for planning purposes but
but maybe not for uh this fast diagnosis
what do you see are you know the
potential challenges or you know know
even ethical challenges here about GPT
being potentially used in healthcare one
day sure I mean aside from the issue of
plagiarism in a medical license exam
um I think there's a there is an issue
of accuracy I think there's a lot of
discussion and a lot of interest in
commercial chat Bots for example
Telehealth really gained a foothold
during the pandemic and that seems to be
a place where
um the creators believe that this is
going and also money will be flowing
there will be products coming out and I
think
um the thing is we you know we want
guard rails and and we don't quite have
them yet right I think we need
trustworthy chat GPD that's that's what
the AI is the uh you know so what we are
looking at because misinformation you
know can can arise or you know incorrect
information so we need to constantly
watch it and make sure uh you know it
doesn't do any any uh harm I think in
terms of the bias we have to be careful
uh certain communities being left out
um a certain uh um patient populations
minority populations that
um either lack access to health care or
are somehow have a history of
discrimination for one reason or another
and that
um uh may not be included in medical
studies we have one question about what
are some other limits that exist for AI
well I like to say AI doesn't like
surprises especially the way it is
designed Now using data so it can only
handle what has been seen But there is a
way out of that we are now using more
and more synthetic data you know so what
is possible and so that AI can be
prepared or trained uh you know to
handle things that have not happened but
could you know for example you know
sensors can only capture what has
happened but imagination right you know
it is much more varied and so forth so I
think introducing more and more
synthetic environments and so forth for
training AI systems would be a good
thing to do so yeah that's what I think
is an exciting thing that might happen
the other limit is autonomy
um you know creativity is one side
autonomy is another side where their
fears of autonomy of something called
General Ai and you know right now ai
really just exists in in the data set
where it lives or in the algorithm it
lives it's not going to jump from you
know one data set to another or you know
infiltrate one set of computers to
another it's it's not really going to
happen right now and and I well we'll
see what the future holds but autonomy
is one thing that people are really
concerned about and it just is not part
of the discussion right now
um we have a question about
um whether you can speak to any specific
Hospital systems or health care
companies or even private practices who
are leading the pack in terms of
implementing AI effectively and
ethically
I think there are many examples right
now so
um I think there are small companies for
example in the uh
initiative we have from National
Institute of Aging where I identified
about eight companies you know from our
first year Grant to promote you know AI
research and and move products from labs
to hospitals the AI and medicine is
going to be slow because it need you
know we need to go through and make sure
it works and everything right so it's
going to take time but I think as we see
more and more FDA approvals and so forth
you will see it's integrated it's not
like you are going to have you know AI
is working here in in a hospital
sometimes it may just be in the
background you know with a better way of
triaging you know people who come into
emergency and so forth we have time for
one more audience question here there is
a question about cyber security so are
there cyber security or data security
concerns around a using AI Tools in
hospitals I'm sure there are many
um Eric why don't you take that one why
don't you take that one sure I think
there's been some concerns uh in in
recent years about internet connected
devices
um uh you know heart monitors Health
monitors patient monitor sensors that
that have an internet connection and and
that can be hacked
um I think you're probably going to see
similar things uh as AI sort of like
rhombuses you know becomes part of the
background
um I think uh anytime that you have
large amounts of data that can be
accessed
um that you that the threats are there
and and you just need to have the same
security precautions that we have had as
we've gone to digital Health in the past
15 20 years thank you both again really
great conversation
thanks for having me on the show great
to be here thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
foreign